each year microsoft research helps
hundreds of influential speakers from
around the world including leading
scientists renowned experts in
technology book authors and leading
academics and makes videos of these
lectures freely available
so thank you enjoy your introducing my
experiment some of you may have heard
previous talks and I'm going to start
with this picture which is that the
picture I used when I spoke last year
about the use of my experiment for
accelerating science and then for those
of you who haven't come across my
experiment before I have a few slides
that introduced that but then i'll be
moving on to this notion of research
objects which is what i'm talking about
today so this this is fairly iconic
e-science picture this is actually drawn
by Simon Cole's from chemistry in South
Hamptons you use by many people possibly
songs you in the room have used this
picture as well and the main point of
the picture is that a science
cyberinfrastructure sometimes had a
focus on the data deluge that occurs
around the new experimental techniques
the DNA microarrays the combinatorial
chemistry the scientific workflows the
sensor networks the earth observation
and so on but really if you want to
think about the whole process of
accelerating science doing new science
engaging intensive science we need to be
more holistic and look at the overall
life cycle and this is the sort of
traditional science 1.0 scholarly
publishing cycle with things going out
for repositories and journals and coming
back into the labs but also to the next
generation of researchers who are very
important on the right and things yeah
my my experiment is this observation
that even in this increasingly digital
world of research we have all these new
kinds of scholarly artifacts the data
we've talked about a lot the metadata
the provenance records so you can trust
things and interpret them scripts and
workflows the services and service
descriptions on colleges for capillaries
blogs and all these pieces all these
things that members are leading to this
morning and talking about science to
Boyd oh how do we share those things so
my experiment is an experiment to
explore the sharing of those pieces in a
in a web to kind of way and when
normally when I present this I say we
can look at the right hand side of this
picture and it's important that it's
over on the right hand side because this
is also where the next generation of
researchers are that's our emphasis and
that one day we're gonna look see
the right hand side fits to the left
hand side and today I'm gonna do the
right hand left hand thing but first of
all for those of you who haven't come
across my experiment it all started with
Carol he's my colhoun is sitting at the
back wave giving who back in 2006 came
up with the idea of my experiment
thinking keynote talks and we've got a
lot of attention including from here the
myspace for the dudes in lab coats and
the issue that was arising then really
and we still feel it quite a lot is is
this sort of suspicion that web too
isn't the right thing for the scientists
to share what themes in Manchester at
the time reserved there's a great
collaboration tools at 12 year olds are
using it all back to front and that's
that's really the issue since that the
teenagers were able to to share stuff in
a way that we wanted sighs it's better
share but the scientists went using
those tools and there is this real
suspicion that that there are good
reasons for that society's fundamentally
don't share as main groups like this
that that allude to that but we suspect
you that they do we've just seen the
scholarly knowledge life cycle in the
earlier slide the whole processor size
is about sharing some live on building
what we've done before and their sons
like open wetware which meant date that
everything on the science of public and
that was growing organically so there
were some evidence of shake so it might
experiment partly is an experiment to
societies we do share it's also an
experiment in lots of other things as
your seat so when it comes to describing
my experiment we talked about it in
different ways to different people
depending on the audience and today
we've actually got him just about all
possible members of their our audience
is in one room so some of your
researchers here's a researcher these
are the these are the blind might seem
different bits of the elephant that is
my experiment this researcher clutching
the trunk there this is the social
networking researcher clinic as it got
his hands on this other researcher there
are developers underneath the elephant
okay there's a way to go out there and I
don't want to put open repositories at
the rear end but I apologize 20
so he started by calling it when I spray
for scientists because that's what new
scientists have done in the press
releases or earlier and then we decided
that was rather PSA so we've talked
about Facebook for scientists and then
we said no it's not Facebook fascitis
right because of that thing I just
mentioned that people assume it with two
means everything public let me think the
scientists want so now when we describe
my experiment we say its face with the
site is the different defacement so it
catches the whole idea of where to but
it has a load of other important
properties which we're gonna talk about
after repositories people it's
significantly the repository of research
methods there's a lot of emphasis in
repositories on data and that's very
important but along with this data
deluge we have we also have the method
daily usual that's being used to the
process that data isn't that just as
important what about the curation of
those those methods so we have this
emphasis on method we think of ample
sharing methods shares know how builds
capacity enables new sighs okay um it's
an interesting social network because it
is a social ago scientists with friends
and groups and so on but also of the
things that they share and we're
interesting to the social network
analysis research team you see people
had not contractor because of the way
that's evolving in the UK we have this
notion of the virtual research
environment which is like a
collaboratory and this is distinctive
for being social this is social
infrastructure so these are all the sort
of different things we are go develop ER
for an open source Ruby on Rails
application as you can see from the
dates there it actually came together
very quickly one of our key developers
assisting the frankly I'm not working
and we spent less time writing coding
more time with the users by using a web
application framework like leave your
nails we put a lot of work into making
it usable to developers as well as to
the end users you know see some examples
of that that later on so now we have
about 2,500 members the members of
people who actually have accounts on the
site as opposed to the users who are all
the people who might have found stuff on
google or seen the URL on the end of
andreas life and just downloaded
something and we've got 200 groups 800
civic vs makes it the largest public
collection of the scientific workflows
and then we have far as these
hats which I'm going to come back to in
some detail and in terms of gluttony and
Google Analytics the number of unique IP
addresses sort of 36,000 or so people
uniquely have downloaded stuff and you
can go away and look at the site now if
you have enough of me what you'll see is
a familiar sort of web to interface
tabbed interface significantly perhaps
this yellow stripe this sidebar here
carries what we call the social metadata
this is things like the the credits and
the attributions and the license these
are the things that scientists really
needed to be there they'll just be
willing to use the Site it manages the
rights flow manages reputation and
that's absolutely essential so that's
perhaps one of the one of the key things
that I won't talk much more about the
site itself what I want to do in a few
slides quite quickly is to give you a
sense of you know the results of the
experiment that is my experiment and
then I'll have you on to the packs thing
so these are the distinctives of my
experiment over the site perhaps like
Facebook they did there is a focus on
the quitting attribution is this fine
control over the sharing in the previous
see that Andrea mentioned the packs are
talk about the fact that you can have
multiple ones of these things there
isn't just one site and fake actually
run stuff in them as well which makes
them in the individual the library's
world a second generation deliver
library it turns out i discovered a JCT
obviously hope to put that on my
elephant the plaques are important one
of the principles of web to going back
to sort of the o'reilly definition we
heard about in the keynote this morning
these data is the next intel inside this
is saying that YouTube does move is that
Facebook that the flickr does photos
that slide share the slide so in a sense
it looks like my experiment set out to
be the site that really really knew how
to do work for us and it does that but
it actually keeps with my experiment you
know is actually about experiment and as
scientists don't work with a single
content I scientists researchers all
disciplines work with bundles of stuff
okay that's why we deduce this notion of
packs the idea that once you've
downloaded a workflow
it you know so empathetic it's not
pathetic Justin research paper you have
some slides this is pack 25 or 56 I
think paul Fisher spectrum is Japan are
some Isis work and that's that's a user
interface viewpoint a collection of
stuff that you can achieve through a
shopping metaphor it's like fixing
things together in a shopping basket or
wish this the things don't have to be on
my experiment this will be pointing at
external content but we have got this
aggregation of stuff and perhaps that's
the first classes and perhaps that's the
thing the scientist vallini that's the
thing that captures the experiment is it
seems a bit odd when we forfeit that
there wasn't a standard to represent
this because it's like a standard for a
bundle of URLs you think that would
exist in the web and solid accession but
then fortunately already came along just
at that moment come back to that later
so that's what you have in my experiment
of the moment you look a good pack still
be these these bags of odds and ends
which are on the site or elsewhere so
you can capture all the right versions
of things and have a unique you are
pointing up there now the results of
that sharing experiment do scientist
share well the good news is they do as
we expected and in other talks and
special is given by Carol give it a much
greater analysis of this aspect and this
is what we talked about previously it
isn't the focus this year the sort of
relationship between the consumers of
things like the workflows and the
producers is much more characteristic of
a site like Wikipedia then it's not an
8020 thing you have a very large
percentages of machine with a very very
small producers producers and this
hugely important group in the middle
which is the group that over time at the
moment we're trying to grow because they
had a lot of values of this into the
magic which you get from the human
beings participating in all the list
gets a given your network effects are
the people who are actually adding value
to the content by keeping things up to
date for example the popular workplace
will be maintained still be usable by
the people who are using them that
was very shared with the others so this
is quite an important sort of you know
ninety percent nine percent one percent
type of distribution but that's another
tool now this is all like a probe on how
scientists do work it's very interesting
for the social science we boys if you
like we give people a small number of
mechanisms you form groups you form
friendships you can build packs and then
we let the community loose with it and
we watch how the content evolves that's
very interesting so here's a few
glimpses quite rapidly of what's gone in
there and then we'll look at the packs
so other people have introduced their
own work phone systems there's a couple
here you can configure my experiment to
run work photos as well locally so
people are actually not just uploading
and downloading workflows in their
formats we're making it possible for the
users to actually run the workflows for
my experiment we get a glimpse not only
in terms of digital maps of workflows
that are being uploaded but through that
a glimpse of the research people are
doing and what's going on in the sort of
innovation in that area this is a
particularly nice one the semantic
people in the audience whether they're
probably in a different session which is
Francois Bello who's writing workflows
that do Sparkle queries to get things
from RDF and linked data stores which
puts them into a store does a Korean
gets a result it's a very powerful way
of assembling thing and we're really
beginning to see just over the last few
months is being used increasingly in the
science which has less interesting
example somatic science in action we
also see people installing new instances
of my experiments is going to develop
them for their own community I rad their
own functionality the one of the top
here is from a project called of pace
they're from Oxford which is marrying
the high-performance computing for music
with the numerical algorithms community
the astronomers not content with calling
something Facebook preferred space book
and who worked on that over my
experiment and there's an instance of my
experimental Monash some of you will be
aware of which the Box Nimrod
skeptical workflows and then very
interested in as well as bringing the
users to the my experiment website
that's friendly familiar sort of website
or as well as making it possible for
people to make that website available
that's where by building over the API
you bring my experiment functionality
through in the researchers environment
so instead of them having to learn
anything new you can get that coming
through into what's very familiar to
them already they put one of our
principles to bring my experiment to the
user rather than the vice versa so if
you are taverna user so we heard from a
draft of anyone into Venna to have
plugins which enable you to get up my
experiment rationality from the Villa
Taverna workbench environment if you're
a google user can get bits of my
experiment crash gonna see these are
great these little google gadgets we use
this as a teaching technique for the
summer schools and for undergraduate
students and mark here can teach you
rest and I google and my experiment for
40 minutes and can build one of these
we've done at the piece together they're
really good that gives you an idea how
easy this sort of build mashups over
these things here's a windows 7
interface which it comes to very very
very naturally very easily to the my
experiment API to actually bring that
through in the DP familiar i would have
windows having said my experiment isn't
facebook here is one of the two Mike's
perhaps for facebook one was written
that is I one was written and sitting
Southampton so that's possible too now
let's look at these packs so this is a
mechanism that has enabled people to
bundle are with your stuff what are they
bundle so there are things on there like
a bunch of workflows that you use if you
were downloading and using to burn a 1.7
or two burner too we have things
relating specific pieces of research
with all the bits of a paper this is
actually a my experiment paper for
carrots apples experience which uses
within it Paul Fisher's japan-us and
Isis workforce all of which were you
another patent your pack containing a
capture who do that benchmarking 44 were
closed as well and then closed all cars
keynotes so all sorts of things get flex
is getting in the pack we're beginning
to get a sense as we interact with the
community for the use cases for these
about what it is that people want to
express and it is more than it's more
than a workflow okay it's all these
other bits and pieces it's the
configuration the results it's the
provenance and the publications the
training material the version history
everything you need so you can come back
and have everything that was used for
that run of that experiment at that
point in time Paul's pack for example is
currently looks like that as we saw
earlier what Paul really wants to do you
say actually these things are connected
together there's some relationships
between them and then we can put names
to those relationships and they might be
food from a standard vocabulary or there
may be something that pause it rentable
and they decide to pursue it to the
domain so we want to have something
richer than the packs in terms of
expressing these things maybe some good
examples of compound objects like this
from Jane hunter in this room earlier
today so these are use cases and in
order to implement those in order to
actually export these richer packs we've
extended the my experiment architecture
as you can see here this thing on the
left is my experiment as we know it it's
a ruby on rails application runs over my
SQL very effectively these are the
things that are sort of a specific to my
experiment the web to principle of
cooperate don't control your reusing
other stuff as much as possible and
making your own stuff as you be usable
as much as possible means that these are
the things that we do and that other
people can be used that we can use other
people's stuff now if we wanted to start
exporting bits of my experiment content
packs we could do it directly from here
in fact you can do some of it directly
from here but as many of you will know
the nature of this agile world on the
left this perpetual beta world web it
would be very responsive to to user
requirements is that this is actually
quite fluid world and also this is very
characteristic of these frameworks stuff
required at the top there an interface
does have an impact down the bottom here
so there isn't
there isn't is really really stable data
model get a lot of it is stable but it's
subject to change as the whole thing if
I was evolution is important so what we
do is map across the content sort of
sync operation goes through a important
transformations maybe it up at home the
loop of the content so that people can
access it in this RDF triples store now
this architecture is actually quite
important it seems to the world via
services like we've added that thing on
the right foot the following two
scenarios would have been wrong we could
have changed this on the left to have
that data model or to use RDF underneath
that would have been disastrous well we
could have taken a tribble store and try
to build a web to interface i agree that
would have been disastrous too expensive
evidence in the community of why those
are bad ideas this actually seat one is
actually working incredibly well so that
means we can have a more stable
we started getting support queries on
the thing on the cart and we put this up
it's part of our development of research
objects these axes which packs and
Harley the service with healthcare
community
see a lot of takers another support we
estimate that again so it turns out that
against example people really gained so
again slice but we won't study literally
so what we bring in to an ontology is
ideas from first of all specializations
between the pieces and acts but also
relationship between the pacts between
the trying to catch
it's different on the projectors one of
those are some of the relationships in
the anthology the swat at the top of the
debate later on the ground from
underneath we have any photos model
looking at an Exeter taking ideas from
game developed by the problems for such
be easy other challenges for three years
and green those do as well so what we
end up with is about solitude for my
experiment which has some specific line
scramble get to capture the data model
of the earlier slide a stable way in a
bit of shock
communities and also they really
recessive different pieces come into the
weapon
so this Italian Karina is offended
friend shot or a Creative Commons all
those places as a baker about this
expression web conference that's pretty
now what we've just seen sipping Aziz
expose local yet with stretch contact
the scientist
the first time you so yesterday
the generalization officially they were
shot in Oxford which i think is quite
useful because he's saying is less
impulse publications with a somatic
emission so you can do some the
peninsula you spoke more structures
some people come here this to the paper
publishing
do they say how we all knew shareable
things we might scream your community
from the grammar say what is it that
people want to share today to intensive
science but we're finding that out but
what's your revelation how people using
the site it's all the same problem
knowledge run around these attorneys
they'll get so all the better
essentially and my experience with many
other places these little things that
being the quad click on that I've just
captured this insert the terror into my
collection their workflows now combatant
I think it's number of workers together
I will ingest me enough in there was
bugging exported as I
suspension is going on I what I wanted
to just to finish the talks elevate that
from that level of discussion we're
clearly unhappy with my describe your
bits saying hang on what is it that
we're sharing it what are these new
shareable objects that are evolving in
my experiment amazing what to do was
talk what these things we will be
sharing the texts
behaviour how to build a specified so
Stephanie back remembering we're doing
this research and here's the piece of
suggestion was there ever since I'll
talk and these we think that the actual
person to be searched
and then all the behaviors so replayable
is interesting because he was automated
world take your testers so it's
something might happen in 30 seconds or
three years to repay things we all
understand that the momentum run
experiments a game in different contexts
for the scalability of exercise what as
cited in the room no we peacefully some
different here be reproducible is
independent third-party we produce the
results or else's plate based on the
sake of this
whatever so we can assemble these pieces
do science but also a boxing take a
little they should be sufficiently
self-describing that you can understand
use of pieces inside
Ruiz
so the purpose of all means were related
to the subscription then reliable in
many senses scientific sessions that
should be robust and systematic and also
his house which we will discuss earlier
today the humid out the loop
it's a quote Eric mentioned will be
so these are key factors and since we
suggest these new shareholders
in the special about this over the last
year law student characteristics that we
discussed which are needed in order to
achieve behaviors or not may have
birdies detail automation ones that I
went into this debate about relationship
neighbors such objects because one of
the things I could have
please make some
so we don't understand such objects but
rather that sense we use and that's very
important if we're working with
increasingly research
there may be taking this food is to look
at the objects our other central part
except maybe spoke with loosely
potentially fortress Louisbourg show all
the fun
just observing the Bears projects budget
roughly seven states of ice parish
thanks to my experiment but you'll
discover some fire
beverages they do some stuff with and
then they deliver the general search
typically perhaps and that point working
with less filling
but ultimately disseminating curation
this book and what we're looking at is
that life cycle understand what is
research objects are so that's elevation
discussion from one of these upper body
active actually what is it associated
doing
sighs and a couple of pointers to paint
this tomorrow one of those pretty
sinister systems work this is familiar
well sharing
community
in urban markets Steve the frontier
involving chemistry these are close to
closing the lab we have paper this
morning to see what solution but
physically and this is being expected
if we set the projects of next
they these are the sort of
characteristics we safely
so people are using the tools within
but we see traditional publishing
supplemented by these additional basis
supplemental materials all this you
surrounded
and comments were really using the phone
sighs faster shift most unhappy incident
what the current set of projects in
delivery
is increasing
a great example below the Japan so my
sis blood efficiently we use the locals
in
Master Chief results
began to see to reuse of the research
objects of information disability
provenance actually play a role habit
doing the science new faxes begin
established and this evoke the idea that
context of iceberg lettuce adjust
curation play the crowd curated by
experts in school
take over around division three years is
globalization servicing the right levels
of message researcher radical sharing
both football and publicist
and the curation Islamic social system
gestational those artifacts
three years we get the same solutions
ways people depend on changing aspect
community curation
so the clothes
so the manifest
what is it a strategy it's moving is
level of discussion up so one of the
characteristics to a lot of exercise one
of them if you like commonly cited
specials are ready we are working with
larger teams we're working with 40
disciplinary vibrations we will be six
or seven flights so started sharing what
was that affects beverage this present
besides the coalition meetings we're
going essentially structure to share
those options so that those objects
should be really scary especially
say it should be very possible
another question
and then the papers are just like you
policies whether you say
you vote he's saying he's saying to me
is the message of actually I really
listened to you but I professor really
don't be such objects
but sure let's do it okay so let's said
that's what we like to see discussion we
really interesting the building
thank you very much
and yes
and
this is examples this is a match
we had never once in their life cycle
might be neutral so in some discussions
we found packet least in from flavorful
place in place of imperative family in
other places tactics persistent once I
press my buttons to and the most two
models are definitely
because we were not especially
certification
in my sleep
the role of that when you were tested
whether or not people we share the
orders carrying so so she kind of trip
call it by a sample people are carrying
all the things so the majority of my
pretty small percentage but the other
good places that judging by the
experiments like I would expect that
security student scholarship that say
they have display
hundreds back scientists and ideally all
of them insurance I've they're very much
smaller people as opposed to the village
is your question we do let's pray
and do next
yes
increase
you find its cool
and that's a
so
then a different kind of community
spectrum as
already a state
I think this
soulful she
there's a cultural change for the next
generation is a changing our practice of
use
my trusty that I teach
so so I thinks I'm this anyway actually
we do what we do
and I think I hope they were also
correct is generic asking scientists
found this nice little hand these
research base of changing your any
search engine
assume these claims about the ship's
really going to have you're changing
for this fantastic subject so yes
by the White Sea World Expo commercial
it's about his invitation for me
and it really worked and people were
really serious I've never asked to speak
at the big while in Boston and this was
from the floor saying we need to share
this is really unusual understood
measure members and another risk fries
so I really feels if there's something
going on inside community to innovation
to bring pets to share at least maybe
cuz sum of money anymore and then up how
to do it anyway but also in between
we share the food exactly yes poked away
from the specific data and some buddies
of it that you don't have to share all
our location data
you
I'm a little bit puzzled by this this
sharing of data issue in the NSF and
very clear very volatile oh yes examples
Oh nsf-funded researchers Apple number
one is I can't really share my grading
yet perceptive successor this larger
effort because one of the guys team is
junior faculty in order to get 10 degree
has to be two senior author on two
papers and the only way to get two
papers out me to do site-specific future
together the synthesis paper okay that's
that statement of one nsf-funded sight
safer number two different NSF funding
site if you publish a synthesis paper
broad publish a paper about my site our
university in the Warriors have told us
that that leaves you open to political
suits because of course carpeting
so well I agree with you it's silly well
I mean put it this way if you just if
you just call up the program manager
event of zak bagans lemon zest yes and
say it's safe it's a policy is money
well Gordon pointer is policy than this
horse policy so you say is a pound wish
of the NSF that you will share your data
but it's not a policy which is back up
for things well except third go there is
one is that when you in the way it has
to be a community right exactly the
review panel has to be willing to say
this guy's not a good share well it's
when you review it in a sec proposal one
of the things you review is the results
of prior work and by the factory jobs
taken into the guys you keep on I just
be folded Tony's getting anxious the
neck will end
feel freaking hiding is great dialogue